I think I'm gonna do better than my wife
and his quiz I don't think so
CDC is bring your brave campaign
educates women 45 and under on breast
cancer by sharing real stories from
young women who have been affected by it
today couples like us will test their
breast cancer knowledge so we met on
dating app we've been together for about
10 months now we've been to Costa Rica
together Disney we have a dog together
see Miss Chester we met about three and
a half years ago and we got engaged a
year ago and we're getting married in
April we've been married for about 14
years we have four children three boys
and one girl
my knowledge of breast cancer is
actually pretty low I would say I have
had quite a few friends of family who
have suffered from it fortunately I
haven't had any direct relatives my best
friend
whenever aunts has possibly about like a
year ago due to bad cancer it really
impacted it I've been working at a
cancer hospital for about 20 years and I
just did a little types of cancer two of
my friends mom has passed away from it
so uh that was really hard to see every
woman should be aware of what may happen
with them in their body I don't think
that's true I think that's false yes yes
yes I disagree yeah I mean you gotta
think about it if it gets caught at an
earlier age doesn't mean that it's not
gonna be aggressive or just because of
you all this might be a dress it can be
either horse oh yeah sure I was hateful
was a true most of the women who I knew
who got it it was still aggressive and
they were still young
oh that's boss you know that boss
naturally best for us I heard stories
about men who burst cancer and some have
died and others were able to treat it
early something that probably not a lot
of guys think about I certainly don't or
haven't true that is true that's true
alcoholic unfortunately is a good and
bad day it makes you feel good but then
later on it affects so many things and
but that being Saint done you would get
so many cancers and all the issues from
alcohol how much say that's true I'm
gonna say true I'm also gonna say true
cuz I feel like a lot of diseases can
increase with alcohol consumption our
chances for disease
that's a chore
I think any type of it can't say because
he can like it go he's metastasized so
yeah
family and a trip to the both cancer but
I'm gonna say true but I'm not positive
about that I've never heard of the two
of them being connected but I'm not sure
now I'm doubting myself
don't die yourself mr. Buffone okay
listen about them
I do have ants that have had ovarian
cancer and I didn't know that puts me at
a higher risk
[Music]
I miss atria know I know that's true at
all
I suppose I'm gonna say false I was
gonna say false as well yeah I I hope
not
that would be really difficult and hard
and I hope it doesn't well I said I
mother good car you did yeah and we kept
speeding a lot there was a consultant
that came in as well and they never
mentioned any of that
I guess the body changes releasing so
type of like chemicals or into the body
your body changes maybe that could be
the reason why your be pissed so hold
I'm had to change my answer
I don't I'm I had to go away sure mad as
well I'm glad that that's not true and
if you have any signs if you don't
notice any changes go get checked out go
get tested you know early detection can
help you a long way as far as fighting
and recovery our bodies
always tell us something's wrong just
don't think twice about it just go
straight to the doctor